a.d you're going to the finals for the
first time in your career when you hear
that
what's it sound like feels good um
you know it's good to get something like
this accomplished with these group of
guys you know we battled
through a lot this year um starting with
the end of the season and
we know the job's not done that's a
great feeling but we got four more to
win
for the ultimate goal so while we enjoy
this we still got work to do
since day one lebron james has said this
offense has to run through anthony davis
so there's no point of having him on the
floor
what kind of responsibility do you take
in that um
it's my job that's why rob and uh front
office brought me here
to be able to compete for a championship
with these guys put a great team
together
and talk to brian begin the year and he
told me you know we're going to go as
far as as you go so
um i took that responsibility with him
and all these guys you know following me
and helping me along the journey i mean
it's tough i've never been in a
situation before but having a group of
golf like this it makes it a lot easier
for
on the me enjoy it
lebron you've been known to say don't
talk about it be about it
and you were all about it in that fourth
quarter out of all your playoff
experience now in your 17th
year in the league how did you channel
that experience to take over there in
the fourth
i channeled it to my teammates my
teammates said bring us home
and it's my responsibility to try to
make the right plays and do the right
things on the floor to help us win ball
games
we have a few guys on our team that's
never been to the finals before so i
took that responsibility as well
and um you know my shoulders is wide
enough to carry a lot of load
but my mind is stronger i always keep my
mind strong and i'm happy to be in this
position
how much of this is joy and how much is
still business to be done
we're going to enjoy it tonight as we
should because this is not promised
every year
there's only two teams that can advance
to the finals every year
and that means it's pretty much 30
players
that only advance every year to the
finals so we're going to enjoy it
tonight
but we understand that we got bigger
fish to fry we understand there's a
bigger goal
but we can't take this for granted
because this doesn't happen every year
to
anybody congratulations lebron enjoy
your fun night everybody
your western conference champion los
angeles lakers